indeed one of the best players in the
world lanier dominguez and lanier today
seemed like a golden chance somehow it
slipped away yeah and made it very very
tough not to not to win this game i
thought i played very well in the middle
game and found some some good moves i i
think this f6 and rookie one and
everything
but then somehow i wasn't able to define
the the
the
final blow i'm sure i'm winning there
but uh just
didn't see it somehow it seemed that
bowman came when you could have played
bishop f7
check uh at some point and moved 30 when
you played rook to e1 bishop f7 check is
supposed to be a move but it seems like
a very sharp line as you'd have to give
away your bit your rook on f1 in order
to make this work the engine gives
bishop f7 trades
and just keep going and get rid of all
of black's pieces
bishop of 7 rook of sound worker 7 rook
f7
and a knight f1
king 1 king f1 and if ba4 then rook f4
which is what the engine gives before
going for rook fade it looks like yeah
because rook fade through p2 is not
clear
and now if root b2
i can take on e4 i guess
looks like another pawn will drop in
this line yeah maybe something like this
is winning i thought that rookie one was
very natural and somehow
i mean all my pieces looked
really well placed and his king is weak
so i thought that it should be winning
here but
maybe it wasn't that easy
already the engine says it's pretty
equal from this position
which is remarkable
a big chance
you still half a point out of first
you're feeling going into two rounds to
go yeah i mean i guess i still have some
chances um so i'll try to fight until
the end of course but uh yeah i guess if
you want to win the tournament
um you don't really want to to miss
such chances and i i missed a few
chances already also
uh the game against naruto's key and
again against fabiano before that so
it's been
a bit
disappointed not to win those games but
i'll i'll
i'll fight and i'll try to
to to exploit my chances in the last two
games we saw wesley come in here
dejected that he didn't win his game
and he said you got to be in form and
then he said well you got to play like
linear
[Laughter]
oh maybe
maybe find another model another example
at least in this tournament
uh it's not great he seemed very
dejected though it seems though like
this tournament is anybody's tournament
nobody's running away with it it said
plus two could have a big tie for first
it could be a playoffs it seems like
there's no reason to feel dejected right
at this moment because it's just still a
fight yeah i guess uh the
the favorites at least on paper um we
are all kind of a bit tired maybe and
uh
it's it's really yeah it's uh
uh it's anybody's
take i think yeah so it's but it's nice
that it's like this because at least we
keep some
emotion and uh
yeah well let's see what happens all
right let's see what happens we'll let
you get your rest good luck tomorrow
thank you yes indeed linear good luck
tomorrow